hello my name is emma watson playing the
party smiley ranger
what strange habit did emma watson have
to shake very early in her career
playing hermione granger
today we're taking a look behind the
scenes and catching up on
all the best blooper moments from watson
in what ways was she exactly like her
character on screen
which actor did she accidentally slap
too hard
okay and action emma watson was brand
new to the acting scene
so she had to learn some rules of film
like the fact that it's
not best to mouth along with your
co-stars lines as they're saying them
something doesn't make sense if all
snake wants
the sorcerer's stun watson had to be
reminded repeatedly by the director
while filming
emma doing it again
she was almost doing too good of a job
knowing all the lines of every scene she
was in
the harry potter cast of course grew to
be extremely close over the years
but as we can see from behind the scenes
footage of the very first film
they were getting friendly right away
was this game of slaps between felton
and watson the moment that the hermione
granger actress started to develop her
crush
others recognized her competitive edge
especially radcliffe
she will not lose
getting just the right fit for hermione
granger's prominent teeth took some time
an adorable young emma watson shows off
all the different sorts behind the
scenes
her natural leadership was already
budding when she was young always ready
with an
answer what test teeth test
keith test when she wasn't busy
correcting the boys mispronouncing
spells
watson was telling wild tales to her
cast and crewmates
she really is so much like her character
even if she tried to deny it when she
was younger
this particular day she was feeling the
vampire stories
an appropriate bit of foreshadowing
since robert pattinson did join the cast
as cedric diggory a few years later
just before his own vampire days i am a
great vampire there's nothing you can
do to stop me getting the tone just
right can be difficult when working with
such young actors
but this crew had total pros the child
performers were often able to just pick
up and take direction without too much
difficulty
bringing magic to the screen and all the
while laughing between takes
emma watson had always wanted to be an
actor and it showed
while some performers may scribble
gibberish or nonsense when they have to
pretend to be writing in a book
watson was really going method with her
acting she filled her notebook writing
an almost
diary of what was happening on set while
the class scenes were happening
and what she was thinking it's leviosa
not livio it's by far
one of her best lines in the entire
harry potter series
but it didn't actually come as naturally
as what we see on screen
watson herself got caught up in the fun
of it and had a hard time getting
through it without corpsing at the end
okay watson even went behind the camera
to check out how the filming was working
by the time the third film came around
considering she'd been performing for
the cameras for years by that point
it makes sense she'd be curious as to
how it all comes together
she got to see what the frames would
look like and just how extensive
the process of bringing all the magic of
hogwarts to the screen was
if we've learned anything over the years
it's that watson has quite a bit in
common with her character hermione
can we expect anything less from the
actress than questioning everything
even when in the middle of getting
directions for a scene the actress would
pipe up and clarify
always making sure she knew exactly what
was going on and why
yeah why is that because he walked to
that rock
what does that do with the scene we have
no doubt it was a bit strange for watson
to have to slap her co-star tom felton
however by this point they'd known each
other for long enough to trust each
other
and felt and assured the actors that
they'd be all right and
in fact encouraged her to hit him he
definitely was
not expecting the full force hand watson
across his face
actually originally said in the script
that hermione slaps draco
even the actress was a bit shocked by
how hard she actually hit felton
and said she had no idea what had even
come over her
terrible i feel really bad i'm not
really sure what i was thinking
emma watson was a teenager at the time
so it's not too much of a surprise that
she was caught sneaking peeks at her
phone while on set
however the difference is not every
teenager works on a multi-million dollar
set
for an actor that phone is an absolute
no-no
emma watson on this phone
on set the boys gave hermione a pretty
hard time for going to the yule ball
with victor crum
it looks like it finally got to watson
who found herself flustered in flooding
lines throughout shooting this scene
magical international cooperation to
make
friends nice considering how intense so
much of what was filmed for harry potter
and the goblet of fire was
it's no surprise that the cast really
let loose during the light and fun
scenes they got to film
there was loads of dancing between takes
between all the cast members
watson was one who really went wild and
made her dancing rounds with everyone
from her yule ball date to her once upon
a time real life crush tom felton
anyone who's made a movie will tell you
that long days on set are absolutely
brutal
the hours are exhausting making it
tricky to be able to really concentrate
it seems at times that watson's focus
was totally broken
and when she lost it the giggles came
into play
they may have been tired but there was
no shortage of fun and laughs on set
just because i laughed and we have to
stop
who knew walking down the stairs could
be directed so specifically
now don't swing your arms okay it seems
pretty simple but taking a look behind
the scenes we see there are a whole lot
of factors that go into it
watson evidently had some trouble but
who can blame her with how many people
are silently and intently watching her
walk
even with all that pressure she managed
to exhibit total grace in the film
you're coming on a perfectly normally
dressed girl and you're not
rupert grint may have been running a bit
too intensely trying to escape at fire
in the room of requirement
poor watson suffered when the actor
fully plowed into her during one of the
takes
it looks like it was a pretty rough
session for watson
note to self don't ever get in the way
of ron
when ron and hermione finally had their
big kiss
well understandably it was pretty
awkward for both actors considering
they'd grown up together like brother
and sister
they both went for it but it took a
while to get a solid take without one of
them breaking character too quickly
on top of it all they had just been
drenched with a wave of water indoors so
it was all just a very
uncomfortable experience that was great
we got it
[Applause]
watson definitely earned the nickname
giggles this scene isn't exactly a laugh
riot but for the hermione granger
actress
it was just enough to put her into a fit
to be fair after hearing that much
slurping we probably would have been
giggling too
red card emma watson
was fierce in harry potter and the
deathly hallows
watson's real-time fear on set
definitely amped up her acting
the crew had a bit of fun with this one
yelling about snakes on set to prompt
her reactions
watson did not hold back when she needed
to snatch harry's hair in the sixth film
the actress wasn't so careful though
since she actually plucked some of
radcliffe's locks
after all they'd been through we're not
too surprised that hermione might have
wanted to just
get on with it and go watching emma
watson grow up over the years
is adorable her talent is also wicked
impressive
we loved seeing what a bright spirit she
was to work with behind the camera
as if we didn't already love her which
was your favorite blooper